Mark: We're in Paris and we're... pretty much all dying.
We're sick.
So we have to make do the best that we can.
We're currently in the Bataclan which is a nice...
...hoh little..
Dan: Theater?
Oh helloo~oh
Oh helloo.. oho helloohh
Oh helloou
There's only two dressing rooms.
Aaaooh *silent burp*
We've got the bottom of the two...
and then there's the
upstairs one..
Dan: Hey
Mark: Hi!
Mark: Hi.
Dan: Yeah, It's the "Windy City"
Dan: "City of Brotherly Love", "City of Broad Shoulders", "City that Never Sleeps".
Bob: You missed it
Dan: ...It's the "Big Apple. Welcome to Paris.
Tyler: Did you hear about the ghost of the..
Dan: Classic.
Tyler: The Bataclan showers?
Mark: ...No?
Tyler: The ghost cocks?
Dan: Mmm
Dan [badly imitating accent]: Me oui! Look at mah ghost cawk! He is so laerwje.
Dan: *still bad accent* Very laerwje and in charlege. Like Charles... in Charge
Mark: You guys are really offensive...
M: We could hear you all the way downstairs being all like...
B: I was saying nice things to our fans
M: ..."Euh Parriiii'hh ahh bonsoiiiirrrr"
M: What do you have to say about it?
(apologizing awkward stare from close cut)
M: You guys are both offensive and liars...
Bob: I was not in any of those.
Bob: I was not in any of those..
Mark: Oh? What do you have to say for yourself?
Bob: S-so--*awkward cough*
Where did Bob and Tyler go? It's magic.
Tyler: Ooohh like this.
Bob: This is--
(Oh there they are)
All right, we're moving out we're gonna- we're not going to the Eiffel Tower. We're going all around.
Heehee yeah yeah... heheh-- I'm sick...
Oh we got some sweet cheese yeah.
Mark: These are our lovely bus drivers
Bob: Magically disappears then reappears somewhere else?
- Forgot my name again, eh?.. Tilo.
*80s TV series tune for Tilo*
Tilo: This is terrible..
Driver: .. I'm your lifesaver.
*80s TV series tune for Lifesaver*
Mark: I'm sorry, what was your name again?
[An Ethan chewing food, out of his natural lair]
[Ethans are social chewers just like Marks]
Molly(?): You wouldn't be very American if you didn't do that, y'know?
Wade: Hey Americans...
Wade: ...move the fuck outta my way.
Ethan: Ohh no...
Mark: Who's talking?
Mark: All right, so we're gonna get out of here
Sexeeehhh..
...fills monkey...
You think this is a good vlogging angle? This is all I can be done.
I could-- this is all I can be bothered to do
I look less like a vlogger and more just like a tourist that doesn't know how to use a camera.
Amy: Oooohooh
Mark: Ooohh my God...
Bob: ... man...
Mark: ...That is the scariest thing I've ever seen.
Hehehehhh, I love France.
Oooooohhh...
That is eagle.
This is a very close-up of my mouth.
Mark: Uh oh... Bob got left behind.
- Where's Bob?
Mark: Bob... Bob please?
Bob.. Bob, hey.
Hey... Hi Bob.
Bob: Alright, let's go.
Mark: Okay
Mark: I don't like that man.
Uhhh, don't stare at me...
I don't like this alley.
Amy(?): Well I like it a lot.
Mark: This alley is a little, uh..
...Leading to something dangerous.
Amy: ~ Pa-pah!
Mark: There's an example of a French boy
No legs... ueeerrrhhh~
Mark: Pit stop.
Picasso Museum, that's all.
We stopped for food. Okay. We got meat, we got ham.
We got pickles, cause I face my fears... We got bread.
I'm done now. I- I'm done now. I'm done now. It's all done.
All done...
..M'keh. We're leaving now, we're leaving.
there they are... there they are.
We're back now. I don't know what happened, we were fine, and then suddenly I started feeling sick
~ Annnd AAhH've LoOStT maAh VoIIcE ~
I don't know why, I don't think  I'm gonna be able to sing tonight.
Also Ethan's sick.
Ethan: I'm really sick. I do not feel good at all.
E: Nuyh noy nyoh
E: ...Not at all...
Mark: Neither do I. So, we're gonna have to deal with what we got and then
Bob: Atta the waist. Attack. (??)
Wade: The waist
Bob: I play football
Wade: Leave with the helmet
Wade: I'm a bird... Squawk?
M: that doesn't seem right. ..
Mark: ..I'm losing myyy voiiiiice!
Wade: You sound awful.
Mark: I've already lost my voice
Wade: Get it baacck?
Tyler: Drink fluids.. Suck on..
Wade: Get it back
Tyler:  Suck on this...
Mark: Ahhhmm tryihyiinn
Tyler: ...cough drops.
Wade: Hello everybody..
Tyler: that looks like you're trying p--
Mark: Hello Everybody!
Wade: Oh God, no. No, go back
[Tyler laughs] (next Joker will be Mark in Batman 2018)
Mark: Hello everybody
Wade: No not that one.
Mark: Welcome to the show! How are yu doing? Wade?..
Wade: Oh God
Mark: ...You-- *laughing* Ye alrite?
Wade: That face just not happening
Mark: People don't use zooms enough, am I right?
Wade: Right yeah, you could've zoomed more.
Mark: I am zooming as much as I can
Wade: Zoom more.
Mark: Oh-kay
Wade: Is that the best you can do?
[Mark inhales his audience]
Mark: *sneeze* Eugh, no.
Wade: Oh wow that's a good zoom
M: *laughing* that's the last sight you see before you die definitely 100%
Wade: No.
Mark: Oh jeeze *laughing*
*more laughing*
M: No.
Mark: Zoooooommmm
Dan: Nothing creepy about it
Zooommm!
Zooomm
Dan: Not creepy
Mark: It's his tumtum! I've got his tumtum.
Tyler: No wait, no!
Mark: Tumtum tum-tum-tum
*blowing raspberries*
Hey Wade, come look at this.
Wade: *inaudible* going on?
-Yes
Wade: Oohh
*Mark blowing invisible sunflowers*
Cool huh? Ethan come check this out- check it out.
Tyler [background]: No the issue wasn't it being too tight,
*Mark successfully imitates a sewing machine for fairies*
Tyler [background]: --..the issue was--
Haha yes. Right?
*Ethan waiting for bus to arrive*
That's not what I was doing.
Ethan: Liked my chapped lips?
Mark: Yes I do. Alright, Wade. You give it a go.
Wade: Alright.
*Wade tryhard master of blowing bubbles*
[Laughs from Tyler and Mark]
Wade: You're welcome
Mark: Tyler...
*Tyler blowing raspberries*
Wade: Oh God!! I got spitted!
Mark: Uhhhh...
[Tyler and Mark laughs]
H- hey Bob..
*Bob blowing raspberries*
[Mark laughs]
Wade: Change.
Bob: Ooh~ho~hon
Wade: I'm trying to find a way to get free coke...*awkward zoom* a cola
Mark: Aren't we all Wade? Aren't we all just trying to find a way...
free coke... a cola?!
Wade: When in Rome...
Mark: We're in Paris.
Tyler: I'm-- I know
Wade: ...Shit.
Mark: Phil!
Phil: Yeah?
Mark: Hi?
Phil: Hi, Mark!
Mark: Hello!
Phil: I'm done!
Mark: Good, you're doing a great job!
Phil: Thank you.
Wade: Phil. Do you have our coke?
Alright I gotta go bye *kiss*
Evan: Fans are ecstatic.
We're in Paris right now. I don't know what day or what time it is, but we're gonna rock it.
Who's excited?
[Crowd cheers]
Mark: *singing with a cracked voice*When you're legs don't work like they used to before...
[Crowd laughs]
And I can't sweep you off of your feet.
Buh-oohoohooh
*attempting to sing* Will your mouth still remember the taste of my love?
*Practically screaming* Will your eyes still smile from your cheeks?
Hey. I lost my voice.
I answered questions. They probably hate me and want a refund for their..
~ Shitty V.I.P. Experience ~
*Villainous cackle*
*cough*cough*
Bob: Wade was just standing and his shadow penis appeared.
Wade: Oh hey, Dan.
Dan: Hey what's up?
Bob: You wanna see Wade's penis?
Dan: What's goin' on... Umm. No.
Evan: So, Ethan uh.. How you feeling dude?
Wade: There's the one I have the better *inaudible* out of the two
Ethan: Pr-rr-*clears throat*  pretty baaad.
Evan: Still gonna rock it?
Ethan: Oh, I'm so gonna rock it
Evan: Dancing tonight or not?
E: I'm dancing.
Mark: Ethan, Ethan.. Don't make out with me, I ate a Snickers.
Ethan: Awww maaaannn
Amy: Maaark
Mark: I washed my hands, but don't make out with me.
Ethan: Why would you
Amy: You gonna breathe on him!
Ethan: You're gonna-
Amy: He hates that one, you're gonna breathe.
Wade: Regular habitat...
Mark: I washed my mouth too but don't.. don't make out with me.
Mark: Don't!
Ethan: We're gunn' kiss, we're gunn' kiss.
Amy: The more you say it the more I think...you want him
Ethan: You told me that we're gonna kiss?
Ethan: You told me straight to my face, you said that you and me, our lips are locked tonight.
Wade: Oh that little briefcases--
Ethan: And I trusted you.
Ethan: Get outta here.
Mark: Don't kiss me
Amy: You're both-
*Mark kiss*
A crowd member: Everybody!! Heyy! (Waves arms)
[Fans cheering]
Evan: *singing* Where are you darlin' darlin'? Mmnnnmmm-Where have you gone? ~
Amy: *inaudible* they're getting on the... crowd on?
*Evan babbles the song*
Evan: Okay, I'm out of here.
Alright, listen up. This is how it's gonna go. We're gonna go out on the stage..
*continuous shoe bap*
Get some of that. Just like that, we're gonna kick ass. That walls the ass and these shoes my ass
Kickin'
Dan: Alright, Jesus Christ!
*pow!*
Ethan: Ooowww! '^'
Mark [chewing on something]: Oh hey, how's it going?
Evan: Where we at?
Mark: Oh, we're halfway through, baby, it's intermission time,
and you know what that means; time t...
Wade: *sneakily whispering* Sexxx..
Mark: Nope, I was gonna say time to ma--
*crowd cheering*
Time to mentally re-
I-- Look at me. Time to mentally recharge.
Automated voice: Hello, everybody!
Automated voice: Thank you for watching this amazing video. My voice is completely gone
Automated voice: So there isn't a real outro to fill that void in your life. You should go look up pictures of cute. Elderly couples bye-bye!